[Music]
making Marco Prince Harry Kate Middleton
and Prince William all attended the
Commonwealth Day service at Westminster
Abbey on Monday but it definitely wasn't
the joyous Fab Four reunion we were
hoping for especially considering it's
the last time they'll all step out
together as senior Royals before making
an harry officially transition to a
normal life on March 31st today feels
like the end of a chapter in years past
the Fab Four haven't just arrived
together on Commonwealth Day they've
given us lots of adorable Fab Four
moments but this year making in Harry
showed up shortly before Kate and
William and they all skipped the
traditional Queens processional one of
the things that was so notable about
today's service was the absence of any
handshaking
because of the spread of the coronavirus
in fact we saw the Prince of Wales give
the namaste greeting okay that's fair
but once the Sussex is and the
Cambridge's were inside things still
seemed icy that's Prince Edward and his
wife Sophie sitting next to Megan and
Harry both couples were spotted chatting
with them on separate occasions but they
almost seemed to go out of their way to
avoid interaction with each other
there was a brief hello a nod of
acknowledgement between the four of them
but no moment for them to come together
for a hug or even a conversation so it
did feel that there was quite a lot of
distance between the four of them at
least the Royals didn't disappoint when
it came to their fashion
Megan seems to have really upped it in
the fashion space megan stunned in a
kelly green amelia Wixted cape dress
with the matching William chambers
fascinator hat and beige aqua Zara heels
she's glowing she's radiant I noticed
and I was sitting just a few rows behind
her she was wearing heavier makeup look
like she was wearing some lash
extensions she's looking incredibly
glamorous this feels very much like a
farewell tour and Harry looked a dapper
walking hand in hand with his Dutchess
in a navy suit complete with green
lining that perfectly matched a Megan's
dress Harry's is is very much taken a
leaf out of Megan's fashion book
meanwhile the Duchess of Cambridge
looked regal in a dark red coat dress
and matching hat completing her look
with a sleek updo Monday service marked
the first time the couples have met
publicly since Meg's 't they were last
spotted together in November at
Remembrance Day events although they
weren't photographed interacting then
either a source previously told et that
the brothers are talking more and
they're on better footing after a
difficult period but royal expert Katie
Nicol tells us William and Harry's
interactions have been limited this is
the first time they've seen each other
for many weeks and I was told it's been
a very busy weekend for the Sussex peers
which might suggest that there hasn't
been time for them to meet up as for
what's next for Harry and Megan Megan is
keen understandably to get back to
Archie if they've left him behind with
Jessica Mulroney and their nanny in
Canada so I think we can expect to see
her returning to Canada pretty much
immediately
[Music]
you